At this time in various countries,
people realised that awful things were happening in Germany
And they lobbied governments and they said:
'We know you have a severe unemployment problem.'
Which pretty much all countries had.
'We know you don't want to add to it,
by bringing a lot of refugees into the country.
But will you save some of the children?'
And so in some countries, including Britain, said: yes.
And they organised what is called the Kindertransport.
'Jews,' said Hitler, unalterably seek to undermine
German's fertility, military strength, and purity
in order to make them too weak to cast Jews off and out.
Thus, Jews were behind prostitution and venereal disease,
delusional notions like international law and human rights
and soft hearted ideas about the equality and brotherhood of people.
Like Nietzsche, Hitler thought Jews had introduced
the debilitating language of morality, ethics,
compassion, and empathy into the world.
Logically then, the Jew must be contained
and ultimately removed from the German sphere.
If Germany is to succeed in the struggle for living space
- Lebensraum, and survival.
Their idea of conscience was, he insisted
choosing his simile deliberately,
a blemish, like circumcision.
A supposedly unnatural alteration
of how human beings are created.
Hitler therefore promised in Mein Kampf
To rollback emancipation and drive Jews out
into their own world or abroad.
By expelling them first from German political life,
then from the nation's cultural life, and finally,
from its economic life.
The party platform, the 25 point programme of 1920,
for instance, contained Point Four:
Calling for the denial of citizenship to Jews and their descendants
Point Five: Demanding their classification as resident aliens.
Point Six: excluding them from public office.
Point Eight: Blocking further immigration by Jews
and expelling all, who had entered the country
since the beginning of World War I.
The other atrocity took place in 1944.
And that was the so called Children's Action.
In our ghetto, they had a number of children.
And they were our darlings. They were well looked after,
despite the hunger and the conditions.
I mean, for us, they were the symbol of our future.
We knew the Nazis are determined to exterminate
every single Jew in their power.
Orders came from Germany, that anybody
who was not employed, gainfully by work
should be eliminated.
On the 18th of March,
a detachment of SS and Ukrainian militia
marched into the ghetto, and they removed forcibly
all the children, all the disabled, all the sick people,
all the old people, anybody who couldn't, wasn't fit for work.
They were killed the next day.